so we want to evaluate the definite
integral from negative 1 to 8 of 12
times the cube root of X DX
let's see this is going to be the same
thing it's the definite integral from
negative 1 to 8 of 12 times the cube
root is the same thing as saying X to
the 1/3 power DX and so now if we want
to take the antiderivative of this stuff
on the inside we're just going to do
essentially the power rule you could use
as a power rule of integrals or it's the
reverse of the power rule for
derivatives where we increase this
exponent by 1 and then we divide by that
increased exponent so this is going to
be equal to 12 times X to the 1/3 plus 1
let me don't let me do it another color
just we can keep track of it X to the
1/3 plus 1 and then we're going to
divide by 1/3 plus 1 and so what's 1/3
plus 1
well that's 4/3 1/3 plus 3/3 that's 4/3
so I could write it this way I could
write this X to the 4/3 divided by 4/3
and this is going to be and I'm going to
evaluate this at the bounds so I'm going
to evaluate this at and I'll do this in
different colors I'm going to evaluate
it at 8 and I'm going to evaluate it at
negative 1 and I'm going to I'm going to
subtract it evaluated at negative 1 from
this expression evaluated at 8 and so
what is this going to be equal to well
actually let me simplify a little bit
more what is 12 divided by 4/3 so 12
I'll do it right well I'll do it right
over here 12 over 4/3 is equal to 12
times 3 over 4 which we could view as 12
over 1 times 3 over 4 12 divided by 4 is
3 so this is going to be equal to 9 3
fourths of 12 is 9 so this we could
rewrite this we could write this as 9x
to the 4/3 power so if we evaluate it at
8 this is going to be 9 times 8 to the
4/3 power
and from that we're going to subtract it
evaluated at negative one so this is
going to be nine times negative 1 to the
4/3 power so what is 8 to the 4/3 power
I'll do it over here so 8 to the 4/3 is
equal to 8 to the 1/3 to the 4th power
these are just exponent properties here
8 to the 1/3 the cube root of 8 or 8 to
the 1/3 power that's 2 because 2 to the
third power is 8 and 2 to the 4th power
well 2 to the 4th power is equal to 16
so 8 to the 4/3 is 16 and what's
negative 1 to the 4/3 well same idea
negative 1 to the 4/3 is equal to
negative 1 there's several ways you can
do it you can say negative 1 to the 4th
and then the cube root of that or the
cube root of negative 1 and then raise
that to the 4th power either way so
let's do it the first way negative 1 to
the 4th and then take the cube root of
that well negative 1 to the 4th is just
1 and then 1 to the 1/3 power well
that's just going to be equal to 1 so
what we have here in blue that's just
equal to 1 so we have 9 times 16 minus 9
times 1 well that's just going to be 9
times 15 we have 16 9s and then we're
going to take away a 9 so that's going
to be 9 times 15 so what is that that is
going to be equal to 9 times 15 is 90
plus 45 which is equal to 135 135 and
we're done